can I we go to set the streets on how
will they remember you it need for speed
that depends on how you drive on the
streets of enter obey money talks but
reputation rules you'll acquire both as
you carve your unique path through the
game but the cars and upgrades you crave
don't come for free by competing at
events you'll win the funds you need to
spend big on your dream garage of cars
phones are important but it's rep your
reputation which is our most important
currency in may for speed after all
reputation is what counts on the street
by building your rep the people who
matter most will start to notice and
respect you it'll get you VIP access to
new events cars and upgrades represent
in different categories as you show your
skills in need for speeds five ways to
play speed it's what you love it's what
you live for it's what you need our
speed events like sprint races and time
attacks are all about crossing the line
first and fastest drain your nos tech
keep it clean and leave it all out on
the asphalt the fearless take the win
and the kudos keep your foot to the
floor and get the speed rep you deserve
style is all about expressing yourself
behind the wheel as Ventura Bay becomes
the ultimate genic on a playground
whether you're getting sideways and
drift contests or you're pulling jumps
of donuts by showing your flair and
precise car control you'll build your
style rep
for some style is all that matters
bill rewards you for creating and
performing in your own one-of-a-kind
vehicle developed by you with the
deepest most authentic car modification
in a need for speed history visually
customize your car with the hottest
aftermarket body modifications let your
inner artist run wild with an awesome
paint job decals and bespoke graphics
performance modifications let you
unleash the beast in each and every car
become a master of the Mod scene and
build crew is all about coming together
and driving as one compete in events
like drift rain and get red for speeding
through the urban jungle with your crew
keep it razor close to the car in front
for as long as you can to crush the
competition ride with your crew
represent with your crew win with your
crew outlaw is all about high stakes
risk versus reward driving
and well doing whatever the hell you
want surprisingly cops aren't an outlaws
friend
so mess with them smash through the city
create havoc and get notice for all the
wrong reasons
outlaws do their own thing and live life
on the edge get out and get noticed your
earn rep in each of our five ways to
play but to create that perfect Need for
Speed moment combine them all hit
insanely high speeds going sideways
through a corner in your customized
drive beside your crew with the cops in
high-speed pursuit pull this off and
you'll maximize your rep multiplier and
send your reps soaring how will they
remember you find out in Need for Speed
tonight we wanna set
[Music]